[Musique]
tout le monde se dit normalement ça
c'est le blouson que tu enfiles quand tu
dois les descendre rapidement les
poubelles quand tu dois aller amener
quelqu'un vite rapidement tu dois les
nerfs des séries mais je les aime bien
on embrasse et stylistes du cou qui
travaille sur l'île c'est pas toi frioua
non non non alors c'est ce qu'on appelle
du bouquin exactement bien sûr on nous
l'expression nadine des klaxons
je la garderais celle là alors depuis
hier vous savez que je reçois beaucoup
de courriels
ça n'arrête pas on me demande pourquoi
benjamin castaldi et cyril hanouna se
sont donné un coup de boule
alors il va devenir plus célèbre que
celui de zidane sur materazzi alors ces
frottements as été indépendant de ma
volonté
on va voir toutes les images attention
oui bah ce soir je vais tout déballé
vous aurez toutes les images exclusives
où personne ne les a vus sauf moi pour
ceux qui n'étaient pas devant leur télé
hier un petit rappel de ce qui s'est
passé à 20h03 c'est lui reste oui direct
s'est dit on va comme ça quoi tu te
démarques comme cela que j'ai que sans
accroc ggp à ne plus rien du tout si
vous voulez après moi je resterai pas là
je veux pas lancer des pubs toutes les
mines non plus mais c'est plus loin
c'est plus là vous allez voir regardez
ce qui s'est passé à 20 ans 38 juste
avant de commencer la dernière partie de
l'émission aurait casta qui manquent de
tomber une première fois plus une
deuxième il est vraiment pas bien mais
il va réussir à se rasseoir vous allez
voir et vous c'est moi au projet
d'émission comme si de rien était enfin
presque
[Applaudissements]
il expliqué on n'a pas voulu faire ça
mais c'est quand même assez violent
savard benji notre rivière prix de vos
nouvelles hier soir vous bien sûr plein
de fois j'ai même demandé le numéro de
votre femme un moment parce que je
n'arrivais pas vous joindre j'étais
inquiet oui je me pose moi monsieur ce
que je me suis dit ouais j'espère qu'il
a encore les yeux ouverts enfin ce qu'il
en reste
je vous passe les détails de ma femme
qui va retrouver
elle m'a engueulé à cause de vous suivre
et vous savez que on est on access
illustre famille n'est pas endormis ni
un malade à cause de vous cette fête a
rigolé parce qu'il avait dit qu'elle
aimait dit ma femme quoi de bataille pas
le prénom mais c'est pas du tout ça
c'est indépendant alors il avance que
quand elle va voir ce qui s'est passé
après l'espace vous allez voir il va
gueuler encore plus alors dans quelques
instants je voudrais pourquoi donc
benjamin saisir il se trouverait un coup
de boule mais avant ça il faudra compter
un petit peu le passif entre vous ça va
être quand même les deux plus grands
animateurs français après matthieu
delormeau
donc ça vous fait plaisir ça voici un
petit rappel des faits
benjamin castaldi n'a peur de rien pas
même du triple champion de tunisie king
boxing toute l'année dernière ça s'est
effrité
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
regardez cyril hanouna et sa tête de v
ner on a quand même les deux ce gars au
monde qui se battent en faisant des
shampooings ils font des shampooings
mais ce qui était censé être le point
final de votre angoisse était bien sûr
l'octogone
mais comme ils tabassent casta mais
toujours avec leurs gardes alors caméra
bien sûr toujours est-ce que je t'aime
énormément mais ça n'a rien à voir vos
mini mais vous de le cogner voilà donc
franchement c'est vous qui me chercher à
chaque fois quand c'est la bagarre la
cud cabaret telus rien il arrêter et ne
faites pas ça chez vous voilà bien
regarder voler ya julien russie qui vous
regarde l'asie mais qu'est ce que c'est
que cette émission alors on pensait qu
baston c'est nier son ancienne histoire
ancienne pas sûr malheureusement cyril
on sait que vous aimez deux choses dans
la vie chante et duquesne j ai frappé
benji j'adore c'est que c'est mon frère
vous êtes sûr bah oui pourtant vous avez
pris une bonne résolution mais huit
jours après je crois que vous l'avez
déjà oublié le 2 septembre 2019 siri
vous fait une promesse est restée comme
ça vous êtes très beau voilà je ne vous
cacherai pas cette année c'est sûr et
certain
je ne vous cacherai pas cette année
c'est sûr et certain bungie qui vous
connaît bien doute fortement
le 3 septembre dans les loges cyril
hanouna continue à tenir sa résolution
retient
mon benji sèment la terreur dans les
loges regardé comme jean michel a peur
de lui
[Musique]
dès le 5 septembre m ap 20 10 ça comment
ça vous démange et un peu syrie
où est forcément dès le 10 septembre
voilà ce qui devait arriver
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sa part de boulot c'est patent voulait
richard a touché au poignet quand même
allez tous vous voir vous allez tout
voir ce qui s'est passé justement parce
qu'il est temps de voir 10e avait choisi
vous allez voir des images tournées en
cachette pendant les trois pubs tient
dans l'émission alors lors de la
première pause bungie est surexcité il
essaye de vous énerver sur essaie de
vous émoustiller un petit peu aussi
regarder mais quand il apprend gaga tu
n'aimes pas son talent il prend une
décision a donc été traumatisée publique
cbc
le
à
voilà c'est
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour ça que je t'aime première pub
alors le deuxième plus bas rive et comme
à chaque fois que des enfants s'amusent
entre eux ça va commencer un petit peu a
dégénéré vous allez voir que c'est bien
sûr benjamin castaldi qui vous provoque
c'est comme d'habitude évident comme des
bâtiments comment en douter en voyant
ces images comme d'habitude benji se
méfie de cyril et comme d'habitude quand
il parle en comprend rien
que ces bonnes jamin qui provoque syrie
c'est frappant
[Rires]
et vraiment tout le monde a peur pour la
vie de cyril hanouna c'est sûr
[Applaudissements]
mais pas touchés la date et je n'ai pas
dit oui je me suis embrouillé c'est
moche est-ce qu'on en viendra même cru
c'est pour rire franchement benji ce que
je t'ai d'ancienneté éléments bien mais
je ne touche jamais il est temps dans
l'hérault drame vous allez enfin voir
les images juste avant le coup de boule
et découvrir qui est l'instigateur de ce
choc
vous allez voir que cyril hanouna
profite simplement des pubs pour
entretenir son corps prend sens de la
graine burlot oublions enfants dans les
plumes en général les animateurs ironise
leur fiche pour préparer la suite de
l'émission s'est lui fait des
assouplissements
je ne toucherai
regardez comment benjamin castadi il va
encore provoquer honteusement cyril
hanouna
c'est tout ça c'est pas toi je ne t'ai
pas touché mais voit le moment du coup
de boule ce cas lui sinon c'est la
synchronisation des deux têtes
c'est incroyable
[Musique]
il faut dire on se gaussait pour rire je
me fait mal mais c'est bon tu me fais
mal jamais mais las et fatigué qui a
voulu m'attaquer t on à la mairie
même en ayant vu tout ça impossible de
décider qui est le plus barjots d2 non
c'est un truc non mais non en effet des
toules et qui perd à chaque fois qu'ils
aiment se faire taper le ciem taper mais
bien huit ou pas douter un petit matin
c'est une faute à arrêter de dire des
bêtises bavard mais juste très agricole
et dans la vie on est comme ça même dans
la ville est venu me voir jouer face à
la fois il me lancer des balles une dans
la tête il m'a insulté pendant que je
joue j'ai aimé ce qu'il a mangé reçu et
je voulais dire c'est quand même un de
mes meilleurs amis maintenant mais si
les gens ne quitterai jamais on se sait
même si ta femme te quitte je serai
toujours là non ça va bien que ta femme
très bien après les livrets je ne sais
pas arrête ça va allez c'est bon on vous
chamailler pour finir comme sur
n'importe quel plateau de télé normale
un chroniqueur et animateur viennent de
se frapper
bon ce qui est extraordinaire c'est que
chacun reprend sa place comme si rien ne
s'était passé
ça qui est formidable c'est sa part des
professionnels mais bon on va quand même
assisté à une première dans l'histoire
de la télévision
un animateur qui présente une émission
avec un bloc de glace sur le visage
vous essayez de reprendre les missions
comme si de rien était sauf qu'il va y
avoir un petit souci on habitue à ce que
vous aidez look assez particulier cyril
mais personne ne s'attendait à votre
nouvel accessoire de mode par des têtes
de bétail slimane qui se demandent où
ils sont tombés et ce qui est magnifique
c'est que vous êtes le seul animateur
qui se dit j'ai un bloc de glace sur la
tête mais je vais faire mon émission
comme ça vous avez lancé une mode
même le jt de france2 maintenant fait
comme vous
[Musique]
il interrompt sa fille via si les titres
de l'actualité de ce dimanche
[Applaudissements]